how you doing there reject nation I'm
Greg Alba I've been up since for 52 am
exactly gave myself a couple extra
minutes to sleep before I hopped on to
the once upon a time in Hollywood
trailer which dropped at 6:00 a.m.
little did I know Netflix would be
dropping stranger things season 3
trailer at 5:00 a.m. at prioritize Once
Upon a Time in Hollywood the stranger
things has presented itself with some
copyright issues in the past and getting
blocked worldwide and you know how fun
it is but I'll give it a shot
I'll see if this video stays up on
YouTube I'm doing it by myself because
out of the two people that live in this
apartment I'm the only one who has seen
all the stranger things I cannot find a
guest to randomly come over at six
o'clock in the morning today so you got
just me I don't know if this is being
uploaded right away the time from once
to put a time in Hollywood perform we do
TV show stream alongs over at our
patreon that includes one punch man my
hero academia did all of attack on Titan
Full Metal Alchemist Brotherhood Gotham
supernatural haunting of Hill House some
shows have reaction highlights included
those are one punch man supernatural my
hero academia as a late John's doing
Full Metal Alchemist Brotherhood someone
just told me on Twitter is comes out in
July so I imagine round July will
definitely be covering stranger things
cover the last half of season two anyhow
Greg you're taking too long to get to
the reaction or impatience of people who
watch these videos which are free for
you to watch and we also do weekly QA on
our page
[Music]
hey hey hey looks a holder
[Music]
[Laughter]
they're adorable
Hey
he's definitely back despite that whole
drug problem thingy him he's back to
stash our purpose
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
Steve loved that guy
[Music]
mayor Klein
frozen to
[Music]
erielle
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
Wow
that is just a damn well cut trailer
right there going with Steven the thing
with the lightsabers and then cut it
back to the anomaly children are your
friends that's a good line alright so
I'm not the best at like predictions for
strangers just put that out there
I saw season two and I really really
liked it a hell of a lot it's been over
quite a while since I've seen it so I
feel like there might be something I'm
missing here because at the beginning of
the trailer they're saying welcome home
Dustin and it was a fun moment why did
he like go to camp or something I know
this is July there's st. happy fourth of
July in this trailer could he go on like
a little trip with his family it was
there something at the end of season two
that occurred that I just don't remember
either way it's so cute to see all those
guys together again they are so growing
up the hell they are that some of them
look the same hate still and then a few
of them they definitely look older here
and it seemed to have a lot of themes of
you know the adolescents coming of age
it sounded like it was Mike who was
saying we're not kids anymore I'm not
sure if that was implicit in my basement
to play video games all day is that what
you thought we were gonna do because
they had that one moment where you see
Dustin and he's and the kids they're all
putting together like some crazy-ass
antenna I'm not sure why and then in a
later shot you see they're all walking
away while Dustin is just by himself
you'd seem like he had that thing of no
don't go I would you know stay play with
me out we're kids still let's let's keep
being kids meanwhile Mike and 11 they're
having a relationship I vaguely remember
the storyline between Nancy and Jonathan
I remember they wanted to put the truth
out about what was going on in Hawkins
to the newspaper if I'm not mistaken and
then they do see that an image here
where throughout the Hawkins post and
Nancy and Jonathan are just sitting
there
looking like they're about to go into an
interview and they're gonna have to talk
about some things they said or revealed
which is interesting to me because I
feel that this is all encompassing the
whole theme of this whole show at this
point because you got this character
that I didn't know Cary Elwes is in the
show he's playing the mayor you do see
these like kind of protest signs look
like there were signs of like no we
still want to stay in Hopkins help us
out even here Jim hopper Sam the way
they edited the trailer was to make it
look like he's talking to Winona Ryder
well make it look like you know Winona
Ryder of a like I still want this to be
your home and I'm glad they're actually
addressing that in the show because at a
certain point it this shows kind of
starting to sort of remind me of the
show Buffy the Vampire Slayer I know
that was a 90 show this is a lot of 80s
references and Buffy they live in
Sunnydale we're crazy it's just going on
all the time and people just don't seem
to move back to Sunnydale and the same
thing here with Hawkins a bunch of crazy
stuff is going on all the time and they
don't know one just seems to move out so
it makes sense to have this element of
people trying to still make this feel
like a home and I think that's why
they're including that giant super mall
which I know was part of a teaser
trailer a while ago they're just teasing
what the mall is and obviously some
shits gonna go down in this mall there's
a standout moment a shot here where you
see the cast of the teens the kids all
together in Elevens she's sitting on
some glass and her nose is bleeding
showing she was just using her powers
and they're all looking at something you
even see it assuming the new cast member
the new teenager to the group Robin who
works at the high screen place it looks
like she's part of the cast here now too
so I wonder if she's a new series
regular member because the two new
characters they brought on board for
stranger things season 2 are continuing
on in this series as well guy played the
Red Ranger Billy daiquiri Montgomery I
think is his name I'm not sure I could
look this up you do you see that shower
he's by the pool is you know gonna flirt
with some girls he's hot I liked his
performance in the second season
my overall felt like he wasn't entirely
necessary character for the story they
were telling seems like whatever they
used him for in that season they're
gonna make him feel more necessary here
because I think there's that shot in
where he's in the shower there's like
something creepy forming on
arm or his forearm so that's a sign that
you know whatever the the villain
element is here linked to the upside
down is obviously we're gonna be going
into that territory as well you see that
shot with eleven and she's having her
frozen - Elsa moment by the water but
then you see the upside down you know
the lightning in the sky all that stuff
in the background you got Jim hopper
back of course our new Hellboy with a
mustache everyone's gonna call it the
porn stache and it sure looks like a
porn stache excited to see him rock that
mustache seems like him and Winona Ryder
are still not together
come on will they won't they Ross and
Rachel that stretched out for ten years
get it done in season three of this show
oh really quick going back to like how
it gets some Buffy the Vampire Slayer
vibes in that show and the like second
or third season they had the inclusion
of the mayor and everyone had a lot of
faith in the mayor and it just seems
like the mayor this season is probably a
bad guy you're seeing like this carnival
going on you've seen the mall and so
there's all these things to make Hawkins
seem like in a very exciting place but
clearly if you slowed down the imagery
just a little bit you'll see that
there's terrible things going on that
carnival you know you even got an
assassin doing that whole that action
movie cliche where they go through you
know a place full of a lot of mirrors a
lot of mirrors remember they're trying
to the kill there they they have to like
who shoot it and they're shooting a
mirror and it's not the person that that
person knows how to how to manipulate
and elude with the use of mirrors
whoever can shoot
[Music]
Thank You CJ beauty I think that was
Jake Busey that you Zia for a moment in
this trailer they're gonna be people who
are gonna like slow down every little
image of that montage there where [ __ ]
is just going crazy Steve getting
injected a lot of screaming people been
fun bonding is a whole lot of craziness
going on to that montage there and I'll
just let myself be surprised by the time
this show rolls around of course that
monster at the end does not look like a
Demi Gorgon to me but it does look
freakin terrifying that's usually how
John looks in the morning so for me it
hit me on a real personal level I mean
to me it kind of looked like like a
hybrid of a debt maybe like some type of
morph shape-shifting kind of Demi Gorgon
you know talking about this is a
rhetorical question because I can
you're not gonna reply back to me yeah I
mean the this trailer did look this
trailer was great I'm excited for this
show I'm just glad it's not coming out
in April along with all the other shows
that are coming out in April July is
gonna be a looking forward to July now
well thanks guys what are your
predictions for season 3 what are you
looking forward to most shredded a good
job at communicating some themes that
we're going to be exploring here I'm
excited you guys can subscribe to the
reject nation click that notification
bell and check us out patreon